[Musique]
stade de farce honte ce week-end la
presse étrangère n'a pas épargné la
France et sa gestion de la sécurité aux
abords du Stade de France événement
absolument
impensions en organisation chaotique
pauvre France pauvre France samedi soir
la finale de la Ligue des Champions
posant Liverpool au Real de Madrid
Baconnais 30 minutes de retard
on ne devrait pas avoir lieu avant
21h36 à l'extérieur des centres de
désordre et de débordement qui vont très
vite faire le tour du monde
[Musique]
pendant que certains supporters parfois
venus de loin vont se voir refuser
l'accès aux portes
doit accueillir les JO 2024 la sécurité
est plus que jamais remise en cause
alors un civilité débordement et enfant
gazé retour sur la soirée chaotique au
Stade de France à qui la faute
allez on va en parler tout ça c'est au
sujet que vous attendez bien sûr ce soir
le gros dos et on est avec Jordy merci
Jordy merci d'être là c'est avec lui
voilà que j'étais samedi soir cette
vidéo qui a fait qui a fait vraiment un
boss de ouf on est avec Jules Torres
journaliste Valeurs Actuelles merci
d'être là Djibril qui a vécu l'horreur
samedi soir il vous pousser un coup de
gueule contre les Anglais et voilà je
vais vous dire aussi moi ce que j'ai
vécu là-bas ce que je suis allé avec
avec mon fils et Mokhtar et été faisait
partie de la sécurité là-bas au Stade de
France alors avant qu'on démarre
j'aimerais bien sûr qu'on revoit
Djibril avec vous vous avez vécu
l'horreur samedi soir mais juste avant
je voudrais qu'on voit cette vidéo qui a
énormément tourné avec Jordy et moi
quand j'arrive au Stade de France voilà
parce qu'on m'a expliqué aux gens ce qui
s'est passé c'est vrai que c'est ça
explique aussi beaucoup de choses de ce
qui s'est passé après regarde
c'est incroyable à cause de Cyril
Hanouna tout le monde est passé tout le
monde est passé
tout c'était incroyable voilà et c'est
vrai que le truc ne marchait pas en fait
pourquoi parce que comme il y a
énormément de phobies ça se bloque un
moment c'est ça exactement donc il y
avait il y avait un il y avait vraiment
une foule incroyable parce que à moi il
y a eu tellement de faux billets qui
sont passés que la machine le le
tourniquet se bloque donc forcément
voilà c'est c'était plus possible de
passer fallait pas en dessous et c'est
Jordy gentiment qui me dit bah passe en
dessous parce qu'il voyait de plus en
plus de gens arriver pour faire des
selfies pour faire des trucs donc il m'a
dit passe en dessous comme ça au moins
tu le diras plus vite c'est c'était
d'ailleurs la bonne solution
il y avait beaucoup de monde derrière
qui poussaient et je me suis dit
directement tu étais là donc je me suis
dit vas-y et en priorité toi quand même
puisque tu es une personnalité publique
donc je me suis dit vas-y tu vas passer
et non mais en plus ça parce que comme
tu voyais qu'il y avait beaucoup de gens
qui étaient surtout tu as vu passe ton
billet aussi parce qu'on le voit pas
justement alors c'est vrai que c'est
c'est c'est une rigolade parce que il y
a quand même des gars qui sont dit que
j'ai été allé au Stade de France sans
billet avec mon fils
des journalistes c'est quand même des
génies mais franchement qui se sont dit
Hanouna il s'est dit va prendre la
voiture samedi soir il va aller au stade
de France pour voir Karim Benzema ce qui
savent que je le trouve
personne il va y aller c'est retransmis
sur Canal+ en plus moi c'est quand même
voilà on est énormément ils sont il va
prendre sa voiture il va se dire je vais
aller frauder au Stade de France les
gars c'est quand même des génies
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a vraiment des
journalistes qui ont écrit ça je vous le
dis les journalistes sérieux je vous
allez voir ça dans un instant alors vous
avez vu tout le monde m'a accusé d'avoir
fait rentrer des gens dans le stade de
France tout parce qu'il est vraiment des
articles ou Cyril Hanouna fait rentrer
des des gens dans le stade mais certains
petits malins on fait un lien avec
d'autres histoires qu'ils ont réunies
dans une vidéo qu'ils ont appelé la baba
ou le baba théorie la planète Terre
renferme beaucoup de mystères et tout se
sont tournés autour du nombre 12 il y a
12 heures sur une horloge 12 mois dans
une année 12 signes astrologique et même
tous coups de midi 12 retenez bien ce
nombre le 23 septembre le monde voyait
naître sans qu'il ne le sache un de ses
plus grands mystères appelé Cyril
Hanouna Cyril Hanouna dont le nom et
prénom comporte tous lettres et là c'est
le drame pourquoi je dis ça le samedi 28
mai 2022 le Real de Madrid affrontait
Liverpool en finale de la Ligue des
Champions un événement qui aurait dû
commencer à 21h15 et qui a finalement
débuté à 21h36 et si on additionne 2 + 1
+ 3 + 6 on obtient 12 comme le nombre de
lettres qui composent le nom Cyril
Hanouna coïncidence je ne crois pas
alors qui a retardé le match pour qu'il
commence à 21h36 Cyril Hanouna les
chiffres ne mentent pas la presse non
plus Cyril Hanouna n'est pas responsable
que du fiasco du Stade de France
figurez-vous qu'il est aussi à l'origine
d'un virus la variole du singe qui a
contaminé 12 personnes en France là faut
pas me prendre pour un remarque Cyril
Hanouna essaie de 12 lettres sont encore
derrière ça et puis encore le nombre 12
de Baba a blessé si l'on cherche sur
google espérance de vie d'un american
staff on tombe sur le nombre 12
avec les autres ça va doit être des
explications à Nicolas Bernica de mèche
avec les singes et enfin quel mystère
règne-t-il autour de ma part vous ne
serez probablement jamais Nicolas
et c'est vrai que il y a quand même des
gars je vous dis voilà je vais revenir
sur le truc parce que c'est fou il y a
quand même des gars qui ont tweeté ils
sont tous en boucle sur ça les gars ils
ont même fait des articles très sérieux
pour savoir si j'étais bien passé sous
un tourniquet si j'avais des billets si
j'avais fait passer des gens regardez
LCI les vérificateurs Ligue des
Champions oui Cyril Hanouna est bien
passé sous une barrière au Stade de
France après regardez après regardez
c'est pas fini donc après Ligue des
Champions non Cyril Hanouna n'a pas
forcément le passage pour un poste de
France parce qu'ils ont vérifié c'est
une barque à incroyable regardez TF1 ici
ils ont voulu même expliquer la sirène
a-t-il forcé le passage enfin ce que
l'on sait
sur une vidéo relayée sur les réseaux
sociaux on voit un homme passer sous un
tourniquet avant d'être imité par
plusieurs personnes au Stade de France
lors de la finale entre le Real et
Manchester l'auteur de la vidéo affirme
que face caméra il s'agit de Cyril
Hanouna
c'est pas fini parce qu'après ils ont
continué donc voilà c'est un certain
Ibrahim qui a tourné les images sur
snapchat voilà dans la commune se trouve
au côté d'anouna l'influenceur
interpelle alors les membres de sécurité
et voilà Hanouna en phénomène suivi de
plusieurs autres personnes non mais
c'est des génies et donc après ils ont
mis non ciré la Luna n'a pas voilà
Hanouna à l'origine d'un mouvement de
foule bon voilà ils sont fait plaisir
toute la journée c'est c'est bon ça
c'était pour la darka c'est vrai que moi
j'y étais je vais vous dire dans un
instant voilà ce qui s'est passé mais
c'est vrai que toi Jordy tu as pris la
bonne décision merci à toi d'ailleurs
j'apprécie a fait rire les gens c'est
que tu as voulu faire un selfie avec moi
et tu as bien fait l'émotion j'ai pas
l'habitude de voir une personne une
personnalité publique un amour bah moi
ça m'a fait très plaisir de te voir
parce que c'était un amour on a après on
en a rigolé hein mon fils et mon fils a
mis ses semis viens on tombe
il était en tong ton Yeezy c'est pas
possible bon alors qui à qui la faute
j'aurais d'abord me tourner vers vous
euh Jules Torres puisque vous êtes
journaliste à l'heure actuelle et pour
vous ce qui s'est passé samedi est une
ombre pour la France
ah oui totalement et dans tous les
aspects de cette histoire parce que dès
le début le renseignement avait alerté
quelques jours plus tôt les policiers
avaient alerté le ministère de
l'Intérieur qui avait des faux billets
ensuite on a vu donc toutes ces images
avec donc des queue immenses avec voilà
des gens qui avaient des faux billets et
Gérald Darmanin qui ensuite ment et
vous avez dit des cueillements il y a
Daniel qui me regarde c'est
important
des files d'attente immenses
attentivement et ensuite donc il y a eu
évidemment tout ce que les gens ont vu
alors on va voir ces images si certaines
personnes qui avaient des billets n'ont
pas pu rentrer dans le stade c'est à
cause de faux billets mais aussi parce
que nombreuses personnes sont en train
de force dans le stade sont des images
qui ont fait le tour du monde regardez
prenez les images
[Musique]
en fait alors
ce qui sont rentrés n'avaient
apparemment pas trop de remords
concernant ceux qui l'ont pris à qui ils
ont pris la place ils sont nombreux à
avoir partagé sur le réseau des vidéos
où ils se vantait regarder c'est le cas
de ce genre d'homme qui fait beaucoup
parler de lui depuis samedi soir je
crois que voilà même Mokhtar le chercher
dans le stade je vous jure que c'est
vrai parce qu'il a eu la vidéo j'ai
cherché dans le stade et tu l'as pas
trouvé à mon docteur merci
[Rires]
[Musique]
la sécurité du Stade de France motard là
je voulais dire que là c'était dans le
stade les vidéos les deux premières
images celui-là c'était dans le stade
les vidéos d'après si on peut les voir
c'est pas dans le stade c'est de pré
filtrage qu'ils ont qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
qu'ils ont sauté c'est quoi en fait
c'est à dire que là par exemple ça c'est
pas dans le stade ça c'est le pré
filtrage d'accord ça c'est en dehors du
stade aussi en fait il y avait il y a le
stade il y a un pré filtrage et par
rapport au faux billets les Anglais ils
ont racheté là-bas les faux billets
arrivés ici ils savaient pas si des faux
billets et un certain moment il y a eu
une cohue donc là ils ont commencé à
forcer et donc après ils ont profité
donc la 8 là c'était dans le stade mais
les deux images d'après c'est pas dans
le stade alors Jules vous vous dites on
se dit voilà aujourd'hui c'est la c'est
la faute de qui euh beaucoup de disent
voilà c'est la faute de ces supporters
anglais où il y avait 40000 faux billets
pas du tout pourquoi pas moi je dis tout
à l'heure tout à fait l'inverse
c'est-à-dire que les 40 000 les à 40000
faux billets c'est Gérald Darmanin et le
préfet de police Didier de Paris Didier
allemand qui utilise cette argument pour
se défausser de toute responsabilité
donc c'est très simple c'est pas nous on
avait été alerté qu'il y avait des faux
billets mais c'est la faute des
supporters britanniques en fait c'est
bon c'est ce que dit Gérard Darmanin
comme ça vous allez pouvoir mourir
dessus de TF1 il y a un instant regarde
si on a eu des problèmes exclusivement
qu'avec la tribune britannique 20000
places réservées au Real Madrid 20 000
places réservées pour Liverpool les
problèmes au lieu qu'à Liverpool et s'il
y a eu des problèmes que pour les
Anglais ça ne veut pas dire que ce sont
les Anglais les faussaires mais beaucoup
de bêtises ont été dites parfois avec
des insultes fortes pour les habitants
de la Seine-Saint-Denis dont je voudrais
avoir une pensée ce soir d'abord dans le
stade il y a eu 29 interpellations la
moitié d'entre eux étaient des
Britanniques deuxièmement il y a eu à
peu près 100 il y a eu 52
interpellations en dehors du stade j'ai
entendu que la majorité d'entre eux
serait sans papiers on sait tout à fait
faux 40 son français il y a 12 étrangers
un espagnol un Italien 8 algérien un
Marocain et à tunisien il faut pas que
la droite extrait d'utilise ce
malheureux évidemment événement pour
faire sa campagne de zéabonde alors
voyez donc il dit bien que ce sont les
anglais on aura la version après de
Moktar et vous nous direz mais vous vous
dites quoi alors bon il y a deux sujets
là donc déjà les supporters britanniques
donc il dit que que c'est leur faute
alors donc Mokhtar l'expliquait donc il
y a déjà le filtrage ça se passe mal il
y a pas assez de personnes pour
contrôler les billets il y a pas assez
de force de police alors même que le
renseignement a comment dire à mise en
alerte quelques jours plus tôt le
ministère et ensuite il y a le deuxième
sujet donc là Gérald darmin ne me parle
d'interpellation et il nous dit que la
moitié donc des interpellations était
des Britanniques la moitié des
interpellés étaient des Britanniques en
revanche Gérald Darmanin il donne les
chiffres qui veut et moi je vais faire
la même chose que lui c'est à dire que
je vais vous donner les chiffres des
gardes à vue et sur les 30 premières
garde à vue au commissariat de
Saint-Denis donc samedi soir il y a
aucun britannique aucun espagnol et
c'est une majorité écrasante d'Algériens
de Tunisiens de marocain de roumain et
de et de lumière moi c'est des Anglais
non mais
désolé mais en tout cas nous c'est les
chiffres que nous que nous fournissent
nos sources policières
mais peut-être que c'est les Anglais
peut-être que c'est les Anglais en
revanche on peut on peut interroger
Gérald Darmanin quand il donne le
chiffre de 40 000 billets en tout cas de
ce que j'ai vu j'étais sur le terrain
pour les Anglais
il était là non elle était pas là non ah
tu étais pas là
par la porte des Anglais et pour vous
dire j'ai fait la queue pendant un mois
30 minutes avec des Anglais il y avait
que des Anglais et qui commençaient à
pousser et on s'est fait gazer tout
simplement parce que les Anglais
commençaient à pousser et moi j'ai
l'habitude d'aller voir des matchs je
peux vous dire je suis déjà en
Angleterre match les supporters anglais
sont vraiment chauds
un sms de ma mère pendant que j'allais
au sein elle m'a mis
c'est pas chez les Anglais qui a dit
hooligans
par la police anglaise justement voilà
la police anglaise nous a proposé de
manière délouigan donc il y avait pas de
hooligans
noirs
de ce que tu as vu c'est si c'est passé
moi franchement de base j'étais agent
d'accueil bien sûr il y a eu un attrait
d'accueil très bien d'ailleurs merci
c'est gentil il y a eu un attroupement
d'un coup c'est à dire que moi j'ai pas
compris et j'étais là je contrôlais je
faisais rentrer les personnes avec leur
billet et d'un coup vous êtes tous venus
et c'est à ce moment-là que bah j'ai pas
pu tout gérer donc quand tu dis c'est
les Anglais qui sont responsables de de
ce qui s'est passé pourquoi ils sont
puisque au bout d'un moment j'ai bloqué
le tourniquet et il y a beaucoup
d'anglais qui sont venus vers moi ils
ont voulu m'attaquer donc en plus ce qui
s'est passé c'est que ce sont les
Anglais qui avaient des faux billets et
quand au bout d'un moment quand vous
passez des faux billets vraiment le
tourniquet se bloque se sont bloqués et
voilà et après ça fait créer un chaos et
plein de gens sont dit on va essayer de
rentrer on va directement
je suis désolé mais Gérald Darmanin là
dans son interview à TF1 il oublie aussi
une chose c'est qu'il dit qu'il y a pas
eu de problème du côté de du Real de
Madrid mais est-ce que c'est ce que m'a
dit Mokhtar aussi mais est-ce que vous
avez lu la presse madrilène la presse
bars de Barcelone elle conspu
l'organisation de nos Français
les médias espagnols sont pas aux ordres
de Florentino Perez ou de chelotti mais
je pense qu'ils ont un peu regardez vous
les avez là à la sécu quand on juge
qu'est-ce que tu
donc il y avait plus de bordel au niveau
au niveau des supporters de Liverpool
donc au niveau du prix filtrage avec les
faux billets un moment on a ils ont
réussi à contrôler et à un moment il y
avait tellement qu'il y avait beaucoup
de billets et moi je confirme je suis
pas confirmé mais il y avait au moins 20
à 40 000 faux billets donc là ça
commence à faire la caillou et puis
après ils sont rentrés ils sont rentrés
aujourd'hui mon côté téléphone donc
j'étais pas au match mais normalement
j'ai passé plein de coups de fil pour
avoir notamment les présidents des
groupes de clubs de supporters qui sont
à mon avis des sources qui sont très
fiables et sur le terrain les sources
des représentants de groupes de
supporters et ils nous disent on n'a
jamais vu ça la faute c'est pas
supporter britannique je suis désolé il
y a une finale à Kiev en 2018 entre le
Real Madrid et Liverpool il y a pas eu
ça alors qu'il y avait autant de publics
moi je parle Juventus Juventus Real de
Madrid il y a eu exactement la même
chose
ou alors j'ai mauvais souvenirs
à Cardiff il y a pas eu les agressions à
Kiev vous vous rendez compte que là il y
a des personnes qui ont pas pu rentrer
cette vidéo euh cette vidéo de son père
et père et son fils traumatisé par les
événements après avoir été privé de la
finale et avoir été gazé regardez
[Musique]
britanniques et donc c'est eux que
Gérald darmanino
la ministre des Sports hier samedi soir
nous dit texto dans un tweet ce sont les
supporters britanniques mais il y a
plein de raisons il y a la police qui
n'a pas fait son travail sur place parce
que elle n'a pas pris en compte les les
alertes des renseignements il y a Gérald
Darmanin évidemment parce que c'est le
c'est le voilà c'est le chef donc de la
police ensuite il y a un certain nombre
de gens il y a des phobies il y a des
faux
regardez la finale vous avez mis la
vidéo là non non
vous êtes aveuglé par votre idéologie
moi samedi j'étais avec les supporters
anglais dans le RER D il se montrait il
se montrait leur billet à 490 euros 690
€ valeur faciale entre eux ils se disait
ses défauts on va pas aller à la Fan
Zone on va aller au stade de France ils
sont arrivés à 30000 100 billets il y a
une mafia une mafia arrête et il y a une
mafia Liverpool industrielle du faux
billets ils avaient demandé des billets
de papier pour les falsifier
le polémique
il n'y a pas ça
la dernière fois
là on a une polémique qui est
internationale toute la presse
internationale se moque de nous ça
n'arrive jamais pour d'autres pays
pourquoi nous on a cette polémique
je vais dénoncer les supporters anglais
il y a eu des choses inadmissibles quand
vous regardez la tribune des supporters
de Liverpool vous voyez qu'il y a plein
de gens assis sur les escaliers parce
qu'il y avait des gens avec des faux
billets donc il n'avaient pas de place
numérotées les les groupes
d'intervention notamment Mokhtar et des
gens avec lui des collègues à lui noir
sont intervenus ils ont été accueillis
par du racisme et des cris de singe les
supporters de Liverpool ont fait preuve
de Passy ça c'est vrai
des crachats de bière des description
il s'est fait courser heureusement qu'il
est grand en taille mais il se fait
courser par en moins 15 anglais qui lui
disait [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] et le cours
c'est joli voilà non non mais
je peux vous dire c'est vrai alors sur
BFM TV il y a Daniel riollo qui a ciblé
les bandes des cités et migrants ça a
énormément fait parler regarde personne
n'a anticipé ce qui a fait que cette
soirée est devenue un cauchemar à savoir
que ce mélange entre les bandes des
cités de Saint-Denis et les migrants de
porte de la chapelle se mélangent là
d'ailleurs dans le rapport il y a 400
personne en mini c'était beaucoup plus
c'est beaucoup plus et ça a donné cette
amalgame qui est venu mais mais faire
des ravages dans les populations de
supporters on n'a pas encore beaucoup de
supporters espagnols dans les
témoignages j'en commence en recevoir
quelques-uns les anglais alors là c'est
ils se sont faits complètement massacrés
voler des femmes des enfants et les
Espagnols commencent à arriver et là
aussi on va en avoir de belles alors
Mokhtar
c'est facile de taper sur les mecs du
cité il y avait pas que des mecs de
Saint-Denis il y avait déjà il y avait
beaucoup de France il y avait des après
les interpellations qu'on a eu parce que
j'ai attrapé trois personnes c'était 3
ans liées au commissariat et au
commissariat il y avait que des anglais
c'est pas vrai
des policiers c'est pas du tout
simplement
je suis tombé que sur des Anglais à
laisse tomber si je restais et c'était
opéré de ma vie évidemment je vous dis
la vérité c'était chaud c'était chaud
non mais d'ailleurs il y a un sujet je
vous en parle il y a avant d'arriver
c'est qu'en fait vous êtes contrôleur de
billets on vous demande de faire la
sécurité ça aussi ça fait partie du
problème et ça montre un de précautions
en fait et ça ça n'arrive pas dans les
autres dans les autres
contrôler mais après un moment donné
quand il y a du monde c'est à ce
moment-là qu'on sait ce que je vous
appelle et c'est ni à cause de lui ni à
cause des supporters britanniques c'est
à cause de l'organisation qui n'a pas su
comment dire non mais si un événement
aussi pourquoi quand
j'ai fait tout s'est bien passé
il y a des concerts parce que c'est très
bien organisé combien d'événement Stade
de France
il y a pas longtemps ça c'est super bien
passé
au départ à Saint-Pétersbourg ils ont
ils ont eu que deux mois et demi je
crois pour moi c'est ça moi mais c'est
très peu normalement il fait très peu un
an pour préparer ce genre de barnum et
je pense que aussi les gens étaient pas
forcément formés moi pardon mais quand
je vois les images je les trouve
tellement choquantes que je me dis en
fait on a évité un drame c'est un
miracle
comme ça les gens parquet c'est un
miracle et pas eu des blessés des morts
de ce que j'ai vu là-bas et je vous le
dis moi j'ai vu plein de gars voilà
comme dit voilà on parle voilà des
Français qui sont venus qui essayent de
risquer etc pour moi ces gars là ils
étaient pas violents ils étaient pas ils
étaient juste voilà ils avaient voilà
ils étaient dans ils sont dit tiens on
va essayer de rester mais les les
Anglais étaient particulièrement virus
voilà
moi je suis passé moi j'ai du sortir
parce qu'on a le parking il paraît qu'il
a été complètement vandalisé
devant voilà donc j'étais voilà et je
suis passé le parking je sais pas du
tout moi j'étais sur terre
autant je vous dis moi tous les jeunes
que j'ai que j'ai que j'ai croisé j'ai
vu voilà
c'était une fête pour eux les Anglais
ils étaient extrêmement virulents
extrêmement agressif
en garde à vue
les 30 premières gardes à vue au
commissariat de Saint-Denis il y a aucun
britannique et aucun espagnol comment
vous expliquer ensuite la police
n'aurait pas non mais n'aurait pas
dit les Noirs
je vous donne les chiffres
du chaos évidemment pour rentrer et
peut-être qu'ils ont été mis en garde à
vue mais en tout cas il y avait pas de
mecsilités
le mec qui m'a volé ma montre qui m'a
volé mon sac il vient de Saint-Denis
comment il peut savoir
les gens qui témoignent disent qu'ils
viennent de Saint-Denis
vous dites que Gérard Norman donne des
faux chiffres
moi je pense qu'on s'appelle je pense
pas prendre le risque de donner des
cours mais vous rigolez mais Gérald
Darmanin c'est c'est c'est spécialiste
du mensonge ah là franchement ça serait
compliqué là-dessus parce que c'est pas
si mauvais vérifiable non mais il y en a
peut-être 20 million il y en a peut-être
15 milliards 29 interpellations et que 9
interpellations
ah non c'est très différent
pardonation
mais c'est pas le sujet mais c'est pas
si c'est le sujet je vous dis non mais
en fait il y a pas besoin d'être là ou
pas là pour savoir combien il y a eu de
nombre de gardiens mais vous vous
regardez pour qui vous regardez où par
ailleurs vous étiez pas au commissariat
à l'intérieur du stade au commissariat
de Saint-Denis moi je parle non moi je
parle de stade moi je faisais que le
stade moi je parle pas du stade ah moi
je parle du stade c'est parce que c'est
sujet
excusez-moi
c'est plusieurs sources que les
policière qui nous les fournissent
d'accord en revanche les cris comme ça
et les insultes c'est des gens qui dev
banni de stade amis
mais l'entraîneur de Liverpool il a
demandé à tous ses supporters d'aller en
France même sans billet alors ça il l'a
dit mais c'est toujours comme ça Gilles
Verdez moi ce qui m'énerve un peu c'est
que il y a des dizaines de milliers
d'anglais qui excusez-moi l'expression
foutent le bordel au Stade de France on
frôle des morts et des blessés et on
tape sur 30 jeunes de Saint-Denis
potentiellement qui effectivement
n'avait pas de billet
Daniel Riolo et Monsieur Torres on tape
mais Daniel je l'ai écouté c'est pas du
tout bien ce qu'il a dit on tape sur des
jeunes de Saint-Denis qui effectivement
moi je reproche à Daniel d'avoir cibler
d'avoir fait de la politique et d'avoir
ciblé des jeunes de sang c'est pas de la
politique forcément
des quartiers du franc voisin et des
quartiers de samedi alors que ces jeunes
là qui n'ont pas de billets
effectivement ils ont envie de voir le
match il faut une connerie mais c'est
pas mais le problème n'est pas là c'est
pas un problème d'immigration c'est pas
un problème de Saint-Denis c'est un
problème d'anglais qui sont venus
dévaster ruiner une finale donc que Dan
là je suis désolé monsieur torreso
pareil c'est totalement faux ce que vous
avez annoncé totalement j'ai juste en
ligne non mais il est en fait il est il
est dans son idéologie donc il a touché
dans les faits de rien du tout Gilles il
faut enquêter un petit peu excusez-moi
j'ai suivi les supporters anglais tout
le samedi j'ai enquêté avec Mokhtar tout
le dimanche Mokhtar donc voilà arrêtez
un peu mais Cyril non mais en fait il y
a un sujet on n'a jamais vu je suis
supporter de foot depuis quand même une
quinzaine d'années et donc j'ai regardé
toutes les finales je me suis voilà je
me suis intéressé à tout ce qui se
passait autour des finales on n'a jamais
vu des images comme ça alors il y a
peut-être eu au moment de certaines
finales voilà donc des faux billets des
files d'attentiments mais il y a jamais
eu les images qu'on a vu de violence de
raquettes c'est de gens qui passent
autour et le problème c'est pas ça c'est
pas quelque chose
on ne voit ça désolé les mecs mais c'est
pas le même sujet une poubelle
c'est toujours comme ça vous savez que
les Anglais les supporters anglais c'est
très compliqué voilà c'est ingérable on
le sait on le savait bah non
il y a des matchs vous venez pas
voilà tu vois vraiment ah vraiment vidéo
sur les oreilles vraiment j'étais obligé
de les bloquer et c'était archi
difficile je pouvais plus au bout d'un
mois
bien fait bien sûr que sinon
bien sûr oui c'est donner les raisons
voilà il y avait quand il y avait 40000
faux billets et 40000 personnes qui
doivent pas être là ça fait quand même
du monde et ça commence c'est compliqué
aux abords et dans le salle après j'ai
entendu dire voilà j'ai entendu c'est à
cause de Karim Benzema j'ai beaucoup de
c'est grâce à Karim Benzema qui a eu
cette émergence parce que voilà il y a
plein de gens qui voulaient voir Karim
Benzema aussi moi je suis allé pour voir
Karim Benzema je vous dis la vérité tu
aurais pas eu Karim en finale de la
Ligue des Champions j'y serai pas aller
voilà il y a plein de gens qui voulaient
faire le kiffe d'aller voir Karim
Benzema c'est tout d'ailleurs voilà mais
Karim voilà et c'était un kiff de voir
Karim moi je suis allé parce qu'il y
avait ce soir était vilariale Liverpool
j'y serai pas aller je vous le dis aussi
voilà Manchester United Manchester City
Liverpool on est tous allés pour voir
Karim voilà les gens étaient pour le
Real parce que c'était Karim Benzema
mais c'était plutôt voilà c'était une
fierté d'avoir Karim Benzema gagné la
Ligue des Champions maintenant ça va
retomber sur le dos de Karim Benzema le
mec il a gagné la Ligue des Champions
exactement bah c'est ça il y a toujours
deux responsables c'est Benzema